[Music]
yo
action man nobody would be here
sorry uh you mind
so uh where'd you work before now orange
delta security europe
jolly exciting was it mate
yeah spectacular
you ain't much for talking are you mary
poppins oh no i can talk i just don't
want to talk to you
let me buy you a beer just make sure you
drink it over there
anything else
this guy's been around he's throwing
backs on the floor
now listen up boy i said throw the money
in the
flatbed try to get clever again and old
boy is getting a face fuller
just do what he says
get in the truck next time you blind
sorry pal
it doesn't feel right
it was as if he recognized h
like he saw a dark spirit
and what he's saying
i don't know what i'm saying
he's not a cop
doesn't smell like a cup but if he's not
a cop what is he
he's a dark spirit it's his son
his only son
[Music]
i need to know is responsible i'll kill
my son
we've deployed large amounts of time
money and effort
in the search for justice not good
enough it's got to be an inside job
you're going to have to go undercover
there's an armed truck driver
we have a new addition may i introduce h
cash trucks can be dangerous
just do what he says
we need a different approach to us it's
not any of the usual suspects
what do you want me to do i can do it in
two weeks
you know what i wish you could do in 20
years
i need a face we need to understand
how resourceful what serious i am
what i do bury grudge
if he's not a cop what is he
he's a dark [ __ ] spirit
action wrath of man is
more violent more gritty than any of my
other films
ladies and gentlemen we have a new
edition h
do you have any idea how dangerous this
job can be
yeah we ain't the predators with a prey
the interesting thing about a guy richie
film is he loves to explore
these criminal underworlds but all the
characters
have their own flaws their own issues
they're all going through something
you're in an accident almost he didn't
make it
a guy who works like no one i've ever
worked in before he's constantly coming
up with ideas he's
very much in tune with what he wants to
do he doesn't hold
actors back you know you get to play
around he knows exactly what he wants
the first shot takes that up another
shot takes place down the wall
he knows exactly how to do it you want
to pinch yourself going god i'm in a guy
ritchie movie
i need to know i killed my son
this feels violent aggressive
blunt and sharp black do bury crutch
[Music]
you